il aura fallu 59 ans 59 ans pour que
l'union européenne qui n'avait connu que
des vague d'adhésions depuis sa génèse
en 1957 soit contrainte de faire face à
sa première session car c'est
précisément le 23 juin 2016 que le
destin de l'ue bascule
ce jour là dans un référendum où le vote
en faveur de la sortie de l'union
remporte 51 9% des suffrages avec un
taux de participation s'élevant à 72 9
2% des inscrits les britanniques ont dit
adieu à lui eu un résultat qui aboutit
dans la foulée à la démission du premier
ministre conservateur david cameron
je pense que le pays a besoin d'un
nouveau leader
les négociations avec l'union européenne
doivent se faire avec un nouveau premier
ministre
ce dernier laisse donc son fauteuil du
10 downing street que 13 juillet 2016 à
l'ancien ministre theresa may quelques
jours après bruxelles présente son
champion pour les négociations michel
barnier cet ancien commissaire européen
et ministre a pour mission de mener à
bien le grec cite côté européen il entre
en fonction le 1er octobre 2016 c'est
dans ce contexte que le lendemain
theresa may livre un discours dans
lequel elle expose sa vision du royaume
uni post break site
nous allons devenir un pays totalement
souverain et indépendant qui ne fera
plus partie d'une union politique et qui
ne sera plus dominé par des institutions
supranationales qu'ils peuvent
outre passé notre parlement et nos
tribunaux en mars 2010 est le parlement
britannique vote pour le déclenchement
du bric site theresa may active donc
l'article 50 du traité de lisbonne que
voici tout état membre peut décider
conformément à ses règles
constitutionnelles de se retirer de
l'union l'état membre qui décide de se
retirer notifie son intention au conseil
européen fin mars 2017 le polonais
donald tusk alors président du conseil
européen reçoit la fameuse notification
de theresa may qui activent l'article 50
le processus de sortie du royaume uni de
l'union européenne démarre
officiellement
s'ensuivent deux longs cycles de
tractations des négociations qui durent
en tout 20 mois ce qui nous amène au 13
novembre
brrr 2018 le gouvernement britannique
annonce depuis bruxelles qu'un accord de
sortie a été trouvé mais teresa mais
peinent à convaincre une partie des
parlementaires de son camp l'accord est
rejeté trois fois de suite entre janvier
et mars 2019 dans l'impasse teresa m
démissionne le 7 juin de la même année
j'ai fait tout mon possible pour
convaincre les parlementaires d'accepter
l'accord sur le brésil
malheureusement je n'y suis pas parvenu
malgré trois tentatives
je crois qu'il fallait persévérer même
si les chances de réussite étaient très
faibles
mais il est maintenant clair que dans
l'intérêt du pays un nouveau premier
ministre doit prendre le relais
j'annonce donc aujourd'hui que je
quitterai la présidence du parti
conservateur le vendredi 7 juin afin
qu'un nouveau dirigeant puisse être
désigné
quant au divorce il est reporté au 31
octobre 2019
entre temps boris johnson entre en scène
et devient un premier ministre le 23
juillet
en octobre 2019 boris johnson annonce
qu'un nouvel accord de sortie a été
trouvé de leur côté les 27 s'entendent
sur un nouveau report du bric site
il est fixé au 31 janvier 2020 le 9
janvier beaux jo comme il est surnommé
réussi là où theresa may avait échoué il
fait voter l'accord par les élus de la
chambre des communes
vingt-deux jours plus tard le royaume
uni est officiellement divorcée de
l'union européenne les deux parties
entre alors dans une période de
transition
les pilotes de ce divorce est fixée au
31 décembre 2020 mais les deux parties
ont toujours du mal à s'accorder trois
dossiers coince la pêche les garanties
de non concurrence voulue par lieu et le
choix des institutions qui devront
trancher les éventuels futurs litiges
entre bruxelles et londres
les jours passent et les risques d'un
odile grandissent énième rebondissement
le 24 décembre les deux parties
s'entendent finalement à l'arraché the
deal il donne déclare ainsi boris
johnson ils se saluent
je suis très heureux de vous annoncer
cet après midi que nous avons conclu le
plus gros accord commercial à ce jour
d'une valeur de 660 milliards de livres
sterling par an un accord de libre
échange global entre le royaume uni et
l'union européenne
semblable à celui signé avec le canada
les disputes avec nos amis et
partenaires européens ont été parfois
intenses
je pense que c'est une bonne affaire
pour toute l'europe et pour nos amis et
partenaires également un accord qui met
donc fin à quatre ans de longues
négociations et incertitudes
les deux parties ont à présent scellé
leur sort l'accord quant à lui doit être
ratifié par le parlement européen en
février prochain